about the size of a house cat this wily  little creature is the smallest fox  found in the u.s  but even at five pounds they are the  largest land mammal on the channel  islands off the coast of california  this is the island fox  [Music]  island foxes are descendants of mainland  grey foxes but have grown smaller over  thousands of years to adapt to the  limited resources of their island homes  in recent years a chain of events caused  these little foxes to be federally  listed as endangered  bald eagles once lived harmoniously with  the island fox never considering them as  food  but then the less forgiving golden  eagles arrived in the channel islands  and began preying upon the island fox  hunting them to near extinction  but through a recovery program the  golden eagles were relocated and the  island fox population is on the rise  again  this is the island fox  [Music]  you